it's time to open the park it's time to  open the park  wonderland is now open I like it when  the ideas come from you know facts that  I'm talking about operation look you  look is it go  honey if you see my cell phone where did  your model go I don't play that anymore  hey get back here  seriously  [Music]  welcome to the mark have a nice day how  is this possible hello my name is Steve  I know who you are you know who we are  my mom and I invented this place and  somehow you came to life we're alive  what happened here the darkness happened  it brought an army of chimpanzees but so  naughty it's time to bring the park back  to light who's with me  Oh with you Oh No he's allergic to  voluntary  [Music]  such a woman those come-hither tusks Oh  [Music]  well that didn't work out at least we  got dinner  you  you